foreign
there are few mythical creatures as
iconic as the dragon found in all sorts
of Legends mythology and folklore from
around the globe every culture seems to
have its own spin on what exactly a
dragon is these stories as well as the
overall appearance have changed over
time and differ vastly depending on
location so join me today as we dive
into the history of dragons and try to
identify the differences and
similarities between these Mercurial
monsters
before we go any further a brief word
from today's sponsor wonder is an AI art
generating app that allows you to turn
words into artwork in a matter of
seconds all you have to do is enter some
keywords and simple prompts about what
you would like drawn and then choose an
art style wonder will generate multiple
pieces for you to choose from you can
then download the ones you like in a
high resolution or you can try again the
more specific and streamlined your
prompts are the better the results will
be this is obviously super handy when
you need artwork or if you just want to
bring an idea to life it's a great
source of inspiration for me personally
creating more Danny DeVito fan art was
always going to be the choice here's a
collage of some of my favorite pieces so
far if you'd like to try wonder you can
click on the link in the description of
this video which will also give you a
free trial to the premium version this
means unlimited art no ads faster render
times and over 20 extra styles of art to
choose from so why not give it a go and
make some awesome artwork today
when we think of dragons in modern
fantasy and storytelling the winged
fire-breathing monster is probably the
most common image that comes to mind
however as we've already alluded to that
wasn't always the case and in order for
us to find the origin of these stories
we have to go back thousands of years
across numerous continents the English
word Dragon derives from the Greek
Dragon ancient Greece had numerous
monsters that were classified as dragons
however none of them were flying fire
breathers they were much closer to large
serpents at their very core dragons in
Greek mythology were large serpents with
multiple layers of razor-sharp teeth and
often multiple heads these Dragons Were
normally found in two different
locations the most common being in the
water sacred Springs would often be
guarded by one of these serpents the
second would be guarding some kind of
treasure a secret Grove or even just
somewhere where prying eyes were not
meant to be some examples you may have
heard me cover before included the
kolkian or culkish Dragon which appears
in the story of Jason and the Argonauts
as the dragon that slept in the Grove of
Aries guarding none other than the
Golden Fleece those familiar with the
labors of Heracles may recall another
Dragon which guarded the golden apples
in the garden of the Hesperides
otherwise known as the Hesperian dragon
or Ladon the Hydra or the linnaean Hydra
was another Dragon encountered by
Heracles during his labors the Hydra was
found in the springs of Lerner and was
famed for its nine heads it also had
regenerative properties cut off one of
its head and from that stump would grow
too in its place there are dozens and
dozens of named dragons in Greek
mythology many of them being found in
water and used as guardians or even
sometimes as a kind of vessel to enact
the punishments of the Gods there are
however some deviations Madea had a
chariot that was pulled by two flying
serpents demita also had a chariot which
was pulled across the sky by two winged
serpents just to give you an idea of how
broad the term Dragon once was creatures
such as cetus Cilla Typhon and his wife
Echidna were all considered types of
dragons ironically one of the biggest
influences on medieval dragons comes
from one of Greek mythology's least
dragon-like monsters although it was
still technically classified as a dragon
the Chimera is a hybrid creature that
doesn't necessarily have too many
obvious traits of a dragon but its
influence does make sense The Offspring
of Typhon and Echidna the Chimera was
composed of three animals the front half
is a lion the middle and hind legs are
that of a goat and a Serpent's head
making up the tail one part of the
Chimera that does resemble a modern
dragon is the goat head that was able to
breathe fire the reason we know this had
an influence on the idea of medieval
dragons goes back to the story of Saint
George and the Dragon the groups of
artists who created the iconography
surrounding the story of Saint George
and the Dragon would use Hellenistic and
Roman templates of the hero bellerophon
slaying the Chimera side to side the
influence and resemblance is uncanny
this also allows us to segue nicely into
our next segment Dre dragons in the
medieval period
the dragons in medieval Europe were the
creature or Monster of choice some of
this influence came from Christianity
and some of it came from the Greeks and
Romans these stories followed a similar
pattern the knight in shining armor who
saves the Damsel in Distress or even the
entire town which had been plagued by
said dragon during this period we moved
away from stories where dragons were
mostly guardians or protectors to now
being antagonists or the villains of the
story The Heroes of these stories were
not just limited to Brave Knights it was
fairly common for a dragon to be slain
or repelled by a saint and thus we start
to see the religious influence the story
of Saint George and the Dragon begins
with a village that is being extorted by
a dragon every year the dragon demanded
a tribute of livestock otherwise it
would destroy the village eventually its
demand ones outgrew the village and the
supply of livestock was gone there was
no other choice but to start sacrificing
humans as tribute eventually the
princess was chosen and in Road Saint
George a well-respected Christian
soldier who would save the day and slay
the dragon this story has been retold
many times one of the more popular
iterations comes from a collection of
stories known as the golden legend
retold by the Archbishop of Genoa this
telling of the story is slightly more
detailed the village in question was in
a place he called silene located in
Libya The Village was plagued by a
dragon who lived in the nearby Waters
the villagers pleaded with the dragon to
spare them they agreed to give the
dragon two sheep every day as a tribute
this eventually became one sheep and one
man until there was no other choice but
to start giving their children away
which were chosen at random one day when
they drew Lots it was the King's
Daughter who was chosen he tried his
best to bribe The Village offering them
all of his wealth but they declined his
offer the young princess was taken to
the lake dressed as a bride and offered
as a sacrifice Saint George arrived at
this Lake and the princess told him to
leave as the dragon would be there soon
Saint George declined and when the
dragon emerged from the water he made
the sign of a cross before charging
forward on his horse and lunging at the
dragon with his Lance whilst the dragon
was wounded he took the princess's
girdle and wrapped it around the
dragon's neck he then took his new pet
dragon back to the Village which nearly
scared everyone to death he offered to
kill the dragon as long as everyone in
the village consented to being baptized
and becoming Christian the entire
Village including the king became
Christians and as promised Saint George
beheaded the dragon with his sword on
the exact spot the dragon died the king
built a church dedicated to the Virgin
Mary at the altar of this church there
was a spring the water was said to be
able to cure any ailment or disease so
how did this Legend which was mostly
told in the Roman Empire find its way to
other parts of Western Europe well that
would be through the Crusades many
nights that took part in the First
Crusade believed they fought alongside
Saint George in Jerusalem and so the
legend was spread and almost became
tradition the Christian iconography of a
saint or Soldier slaying a dragon on
Horseback existed even before Saint
George as early as the 7th Century
although there is some contention as to
whether these figures were dragons the
oldest depiction we have would be that
of Saint Theodore slaying a dragon in
the 10th Century earning him the name
Theodore the Dragon Slayer the motif of
the saintly dragon slayer would be
transferred from a saint Theodore to
Saint George and it would then be mostly
associated with him from a religious
standpoint there was more to dragons
than just being terrifying monsters many
have equated dragons to symbolizing the
conflicts between Christian and Pagan
beliefs the dragons in these stories
were symbolic of pagans threatening the
virtue of Christian maidens the Knight
eventually slaying the dragon or
symbolic of Christianity defeating What
was seen as the Pagan Menace one of the
more strange stories involves Margaret
of Antioch otherwise known as Saint
Marina the great martyr Margaret was
born into a pagan family her mother died
shortly after her birth and she was
taken care of by a Christian nurse after
taking a vow to God she was disowned by
her father and adopted by her nurse the
Roman Governor olibrias took a liking to
her and asked her to marry him but she
would have to denounce Christianity
Furious Margaret would dare to decline
his proposal she was imprisoned and
tortured one night Margaret was visited
by Satan in the shape of a dragon her
prayers were ignored and the dragon
swallowed her whole inside of his
stomach Margaret made the shape of a
cross which caused the dragon to feel
like his insides were being torn apart
he would eventually open his mouth and
Margaret miraculously escaped unharmed
however she was decapitated soon after
for declining the marriage so there is
no happy ending in this story just the
devil taking the form of a dragon the
association of dragons with acts of evil
and demons would remain in religious
stories Tales of dragons appearing and
swallowing Rich noble men and women who
who had sinned were fairly common the
story of Saint Marcellus a bishop in
Paris involves a dragon entering his
small village and devouring a noble
woman who had sinned Marcella struck the
dragon multiple times and using a leash
he led the dragon out of the village
banishing him to the forest he came from
never to return definitely some
similarities to the story of Saint
George in the dragon the medieval period
in Western Europe is when the images and
depictions of dragons began to change
the Towering multiple-headed serpents
the Greeks and Romans spoke about began
to look more like lizards or dinosaurs
with four legs and bat-like wings one
theory is that these images were just
drawn incorrectly in early medieval
beastiaries and honestly it's not even
that much of a stretch many of these
depictions do simply resemble a serpent
with legs and wings added on not exactly
the modern day dragons were used to but
they still differ from the original
depictions if we place them on a
timeline of sorts we can see the gradual
change or evolution in how we used to
depict dragons to how we depict them
today the idea of four-legged dragons
isn't something we see until the 15th
century this is also around the time
when medieval bestiaries in Scotland
Ireland and England began to distinguish
between different types of dragons those
with four legs were the common dragon
and those who had two were considered a
wyven both regular dragons and wyverns
were used throughout medieval Britain as
symbols on crests and Banners the Welsh
flag itself contains a red dragon some
of the early Welsh manuscripts describe
a battle between a red dragon and an
invading white dragon the red
representing the britons and the whites
representing the Jackson Invaders
one of my favorite stories in Norse
mythology regarding a dragon is the
story of fafnir this story begins with
the Dwarven King kraidma and his three
sons fafnir Regan and OTA cradmar and
his sons were all capable of
shape-shifting
OTA was a great fisherman who would take
the form of an otter one day when
fishing he was killed by Loki who had
mistaken him for an ordinary otter Loki
a guest in kraidmar's Kingdom presented
him with the spoils of his hunt however
the dwarves immediately recognize their
brother kraydma and his sons captured
Loki and used him as Ransom demanding
that Odin provide them with Otter's
waiting gold Odin accepted leaving the
responsibility of gathering the gold to
Loki as this was his mess to fix Loki
remembered seeing a giant Pike in the
same River as OTA hiding his treasure
the fish was the dwarf anvari Loki
returned to the river and caught the
pike forcing anvari to shapeshift back
and take him to his fortune anvari had
no choice and took Loki to his treasure
located behind a waterfall he explained
that his magical ring anvadenot was the
cause of his great treasure he pleaded
with Loki he could take all of the
treasure but not the magical ring and so
Loki did as expected he took the entire
treasure along with the magical ring
back to kreidmar to make up for
murdering his son before leaving anvari
cursed the ring to bring Misfortune and
destruction to whoever possessed it Loki
handed over the treasure to pay his debt
to kreidmar as the ring was cursed he
also gave him the ring as a gesture of
Goodwill little did trademark know the
Ring's curse had already begun to take
root in his kingdom fafnir and Reagan
began to resent their father they wanted
the ring and his treasure all for
themselves eventually they could not
control their desire and so they killed
their father fafnir then transformed
into a dragon and forced his brother
Reagan out of what was now his kingdom
he remained in the form of a dragon so
he could guard his treasure fafnir would
terrorize the surrounding Villages and
breathe poison into the land around his
kingdom so no one would dare to enter no
one except for the hero sigured The
volsunga Saga details his adventures as
well as the death of fafnir Reagan
assisted the hero sigured in reforging
his father's Broken Sword Graham in
return sigurd would slay the dragon
fafnir he advised sigurd to dig a hole
at the stream fafnir visited there he
would be able to weight and ambush's
brother disguised as an old man Odin
advised to maybe dig multiple holes to
drain the dragon's blood when fafnir
appeared sigurd stabbed him in the
shoulder before fafnir died he asked who
the man who killed him was and who had
sent him he figured out that it was his
brother Reagan who was responsible and
told sigurd that Reagan would also be
responsible for his death sigurd cut out
fafnir's heart and Reagan who had
returned to his father's Kingdom began
to drink fafnir's blood upon seeing the
heart he requested sigurd gave him
fafnir's heart to eat sigurd began to
roast fafnir's heart over the fire
whilst doing so he burnt his finger and
when he placed it in his mouth fafnir's
blood granted him the power to
understand the speech of birds he could
overhear them discussing Reagan and his
treacherous ways the Birds advised him
to eat the heart for himself and slay
Reagan sigured ate part of the heart he
then took out his sword and decapitated
Reagan and thus ends the bloodline of
creedmar now if you're thinking this
story sounds slightly familiar to that
of a certain Mr Tolkien that's because
Tolkien was a huge admirer of Norse
mythology and its influences are quite
apparent in his work the magical ring
that brings disaster and Misfortune
corrupting those in its possession is
rather similar to the One Ring fafnir
himself can be compared to several
characters Smaug is a greedy Dragon who
protects his stolen treasure in a
Dwarven Kingdom being the slightly more
obvious comparison fafnir's greed an
obsession which lead to him murdering
those around him whom he cares about is
mirrored in tolkien's Golem both
characters are corrupted by the cursed
ring and develop into more monstrous
forms of themselves in some of tolkien's
unpublished and lesser-known works he
describes the gold hoarding Dragon
glaurang who does not breathe fire but
instead poison much like dragons in
Norse mythology he is also wingless when
he is killed by the character taurian
they also have a conversation similar to
that of sigurd and fafnir in East Asian
culture dragons have a slightly
different appearance but where they
really differ is in what they represent
and symbolize so far we've seen dragons
as protectors and Guardians we saw they
became symbols of greed and evil in some
cases they even represented the devil
either way they became somewhat of a bad
Omen creatures that were feared in China
dragons are seen as signs of good
fortune that appear to those who are
deserving they represent strength and
power someone of high esteem who who had
achieved great things would be compared
to a dragon whereas someone who had
achieved nothing would be compared to a
creature such as a worm it's fair to say
that in terms of an animal hierarchy in
China dragons are at the very top and
this is reflected in their mythology and
storytelling The Chosen companion or
Mount of their gods and heroes was
almost always a dragon the Chinese
dragon known as lung is normally
depicted as a four-legged serpent-like
creature which is why its origin is
thought to be from a snake or alligator
given their association with strength
and power dragons were a symbol used by
Chinese Emperors one recurring theme
amongst the oldest depictions of dragons
is their association with bodies of
water here dragons were seen as rulers
of waterfalls rivers and the Sea there
are even four dragon Kings each
representing the four C's or May major
bodies of water in China they were also
thought to control the weather the
Dragon King being referred to as the
dispenser of rain in Korea dragons are
fairly similar to their Chinese
counterparts however they are known to
have a much larger beard
in Egyptian mythology there is the giant
serpent AP who resides in the Underworld
AP was the embodiment of chaos The
Serpent of the Nile or the evil dragon
the greatest enemy of RA every day there
would be a battle between apep and the
god Ra apip was forced to remain in the
Underworld from Sunrise until sunset a
great battle between the two would ensue
in the darkness from which ra would
emerge the Victor meaning he would ride
his barge across the sky the following
morning and that there would be another
Sunrise AP much like the Greek and other
ancient dragons took the form of a
serpent and bears very little
resemblance to modern day dragons
as we've seen today dragons throughout
the ages have changed dramatically and
not just in appearance but also in their
character a greedy gold hoarding
creature with contempt for everyone
around them is a fairly common Trope in
modern fantasy you can find stories
where dragons are noble creatures
protectors and Guardians as they were in
the past however these stories aren't as
common we rarely see wingless dragons
that resemble serpents we honestly don't
even see the medieval depictions of
dragons often the medium-sized reptilian
creatures with small bat-like Wings have
been replaced by these enormous and
Grand monsters with huge wingspans that
breathe fire and soar through the sky
it's difficult to look at a modern
dragon and guess a creature of origin as
we used to what once resembled a snake
or crocodile has become an amalgamation
of many aspects and different creatures
the dragon despite not being a real
creature has very much become its own
creature
once again a big thank you to today's
sponsor wonder if you'd like to try them
out then you can use my link in the
description of this video to get
yourself a free trial to their premium
version
thank you